il y a des dinosaures sur la lune on y
retourne en 2025 et les astronautes
pourraient bien y trouver des crânes de
T-Rex évidemment ils n'ont jamais vécu
mais ont été propulsés par le crash de
l'astéroïde qui les a éradiqués il y a
66 millions d'années un impact si
violent que ça a créé un trou vie de
spatial dans l'atmosphère aspirant
violemment tout ce qu'il y avait à la
surface dont nos tirex carbonisés et
congelé qui avec la gravité lunaire on
finit à sa surface on pourrait bien en
retrouver les traces selon pas mal de
chercheurs suffit de chercher surtout
que sur la Lune il n'y a pas d'air pas
de microbes rien pour détériorer l'ADN
oui enfin non il y a les rayonnements
solaires et ça ça fait mal il faudrait
chercher à l'ombre le seul moyen de
vérifier c'est d'y aller plus qu'à
attendre pour savoir si